il ya tout le monde sait ce quiz est ce
que j'ai un début de calvitie alors je
profite d'abord encore des cheveux et
nous revoilà le vent cette foutue porte
excite qui nécessite une clé oui je sais
lire n'oubliez pas comme on peut le voir
cette démarche nous avons la jambe
complètement cassés qui fait que si on
est poursuivi on se fera bien rattrapé
le haut tout jamais ça jamais pièces des
portes mais s'en fout quoi je suppose
que c'est fermé bien évidemment je
suppose que c'est fermé bien évident à
watts
ah j'aime pas trop ça je préfère ignorer
y avait des sorte de cocon humains au
plafond un peu comme des insectes mais
non mais des humains
la cuisine de la table sur qui l'on va
faire yep avec une jambe cassée faut le
voilà comme ça c'est ça qu'on veut voir
la poésie bien fort c'est un spectacle
de patrick 18 vod vite et maintenant est
ce que pat xfr la peinture bien sûr que
nous alors quelqu'un a tenté de
s'échapper mais ça n'a pas trop marché
auparavant alors s'il a voulu s'échapper
par là ça veut dire qu'il ya un truc qui
permet de poursuivre je suppose je ne
suis pas serein et attendez yes
nous y sommes prêts mais attends mais où
sont les cheveux te lustres un peu le
craft terminé on s'en va ah non regardez
à c'est vraiment glauque 1 elle me dit
pas qu'on va retrouver l'autre
psychopathe là qui parle tout le temps
de se marier et d'avoir des enfants
caron bizarre ok moment où je dis ça
alors qu'ils sont bien en bas à gauche
la [ __ ] quoi est la rentrée scolaire
2015 quoi alors les enfants vous êtes
content
mais ça va c'est rien oh là là je me
sens tellement mal tellement mal mon
gars au quand j'étais petit mais
l'invité souvent marie toi fils et tu
verras comme tu seras heureux il est de
retour
je rêvais en passer par là où la lumière
perso à courre coco a choqué des ânes ou
là à
je le sens voga sauvegarde a vite yens
kg piques les cours non c'est pas moi je
suis une mariée je suis une mariée week
genre mais non je suis normal
mais j'ai quand même repéré la petite
faille qui va nous permet de lui
échapper
tu chantes la clé à il était avec
derrière court court concourra je
déteste ça [ __ ] ils peuvent attraper
le bras comme ça comme une allumette
très très vite il va se passer on est
d'accord jusqu'à présent les ennemis ne
pouvait pas mais c'est le genre
d'obstacle sais pas pourquoi mais dans
hot l'aston savent passerait de profil
mais on va pas se plaindre
non bien sûr que non non non bah non il
est où où es tu j'aimerais bien que les
piles puisse tuer les ennemis c'est vrai
aucun centre ce serait vraiment bien
est-ce qu'il est pas là le mec est ce
qui n'est pas allongé comme ça que peter
de fourbe la folle tenté ben oui dans la
vie faut tenter les choses voilà un bon
je t'aimais si tu as vécu me défendre je
t'aimerai encore plus mais qui es tu
soit vous allez bien avec les autres
je ne le sens pas trop ok il faut y
aller non mais faut y aller un moment
faut porter ses portes et ses testicules
à demain non non non surtout pas surtout
pas ben là c'est mort on est foutu ouais
je te fais telle qu'est ce que tu vas
faire tu vas faire un bon je t'attends
tu sais pas qui je suis moi ah ben non
mais ça donc ce n'était pas au quai de
riders et 2,3 ok on y va c'est parti il
me tend un il me tend cet homme
absolument horrible coanimer l'émission
vous avez vu je suis tête la brèche que
j'ai des frissons et qui est beau gosse
quand il avait pris son j'ai trouvé
l'endroit où nous devons aller et de
passer devant mais il va être là c'est
sûr bâtard je m'en fous là il faut qu'on
se cache pas qu'on se gâche faut qu'on
se cache a donc j'entends jean temps
j'entends c'est pas de fourbe haut et là
j'ai vu une main j'ai vu une main
tu aurais pu être belle mais je suis
belle et questions ainsi nul à je suis
pas je suis pas moche il a trouvé ou
complexes en revanche l'asie bim qui
passe au dessus y est tu continues je
croise était pas là
non voilà c'est mort
je pense qu'on peut dire que c'est mort
bien sûr aller à wim acheter il m'a
peut-être laissé une chance c'est la
chance de ma vie je vais la saisir et
mon finir en passant par dessous
décalage par milliers ah non non non bah
oui bah oui oh non pas encore non mais
ça suffit non seulement au nom à bata
non non non non non non quoi avec ta
jambe cassée on nous a tempéré ses piles
au même endroit que tout à l'heure en
plus c'est tout bien millions il va le
rattraper par les jambes qu'est-ce que
je suis content de moi ton crâne chauve
mon gars est-ce qu'on peut à aller tout
le monde va gueuler s'il vous plaît à aa
à aa
c'est quoi cette coupe de cheveux ou
allez vas t'en vas encore merci un bon
ça on s'appelle hockey sauvegarde alors
qu'est ce que ça va nous poursuivre dans
la cuisine cauchemar en cuisine et pas
passer non c'est bon je passe c'est
cette porte ouverte se serait passée par
là mais apparemment non
je surveille tout de même j'ai peur
c'est l'heure de la sortie
non non non non non oh [ __ ] au
tévelave par arrête de me taper ça
suffit
je suis déjà bosse encore tu peux
prendre comme le reste d'entre elles est
plus lourde que j'ai eues en a l'air si
c'est la lune de miel je peine à
imaginer notre anniversaire
apparemment je suis trop lourde chute au
tapis pour persos sont en surpoids
actuellement ça ne me va pas mourir ici
non mais c'est trop glauque or s'il vous
plaît non je refuse au oui il va tomber
pour une fois il va tout mais
positivement si je puis dire très
surveillés par des merdes est-ce que
bordeaux tiens tiens toi bien à garg
ah oui du coup la corde oui ou non on
est plus lourd que lui oui ils sont les
petites souris
oui oui je pas ce qui va se passer mais
boîte attendait qu est ce qui lui était
arrivé à temps je veux le voir là qu'est
ce tu fais là haut mais nous aurions
peut être si bon au [ __ ] est bien
décédé en plus et ben vous souhaites tu
ne peux pas de rentrée scolaire 2015
à bientôt moi je retourne voir mon ami
au crâne chauve à bientôt
au nom de ce peuple est redescendu qui
marche avec une barre au travers de lui
à elle est là la sortie vous sentez vous
sentez les affres et la non moi je ne
sens pas donc j'espère que vous pouvez
me rassurer sauvegarde
alors elle un couloir ok c'est destiné
glisse c'était quoi
en tout cas ça brûle bien mais comme il
faut alors au y avait un mec les vingt
mecs copains au c
c'est l'armée on va terminer ici
retournez aux camions mais oui c'est
l'armée mon gars aidez moi s'il vous
plaît ah non mais à tous les coups ils
vont ils vont être retournée contre moi
je sais pas de quelle manière ni comment
mais allons-y doucement moi j'ai pas
trop compris des brutes tirées tout
pourquoi la france est elle autorisée
pour toutes les équipes tuer tout ce qui
bouge hommes et non me dites pas que je
vais me fight condé mec de l'armée quoi
squeeze verre armé
on a une pile au oui il faut aller mais
bon moi je suis je vais vers la lumière
voilà besoin de soutien on a besoin
d'être bien reçus on arrive à wii allait
les aider comme ça moi je me faufile up
jusqu'à la sortie
séméga beau regarder avec les petites
particules assassin un peu moins beau
oui bon folies d'hier des rideaux des
rideaux des rideaux et l'envoi du bout
derrière ammann 2e une porte via petite
musique là j'ai reçu que c'est la
musique et indique tué presque livre une
porte condamnée mais toutes les portes
sont condamnés et ce quoi ce délire
non non non non alors pour tous ceux qui
ont vu des vidéos sur how classe tu pas
le dlc mais outlast c'est l'endroit au
tout début du jeu dans lequel le mec
arrive même après il passe entre deux
objets comme ça il ya un gros mais
cochrane en forme de dôme qui l'attrapé
tout et toi t'es tu joues et tu perds
c'est génial ça rejoint la première
partie du jeu en fait on n'a pas d'autre
choix que de descendre les marches au
nom mais c'est génial mais oui le
regarder la base sur deux roues ya le
mec ce sens sur voie là bas il est là
d'habitude il est assis là dessus là il
a pris congé il est parti en vacances
j'en sais rien mais d'habitude il est là
dessus son travail c'est de se lever et
de faire peur aux mecs qui passent et
pas à l'aller comme au retour
elle a pris sur cet été mais c'est sûr
mais c'est génial on se retrouve dans
l'endroit du début quoi je suis comme un
enfant mal géré chaude à disneyland
mais cette part comment est il possible
que vous soyez encore en vie faisons un
marché vous m'aider et je vous aiderai
va chier regard mes fesses et voilà vous
voyez encore quelqu'un qui est habitué
de la fée exploitation c'est dingue et a
même fait peur je sais qu'il va faire un
truc là quand je vais vouloir passer
allez on y va on y va au courant à jeter
sur jeter sur crête bordel
non non non c'est pris un coup de
couteau non on va pas décédé là soit
possible oh non non non non non
personne ne peut savoir faire ce mode
non
ont l'esprit qui étaient là au début du
day 6 aux seniors au dieu tout puissant
comment est-ce qu'il est sorti j'en sais
rien mais il est là bon gars et toi tu
es plus là haut mais non et moi l'esprit
me fait rien au plus tôt mais c'est
superbe c'est jackpot tout gagné on va
pouvoir s'enfuir j'y crois pas habité
par un coup de couteau donc c'est un peu
normal qu'ils étaient mal au ventre
c'est pas terrible je te rassure le sens
inouï de l'ofc et j'étais vraiment pris
un coup de couteau à vendin puisqu'on
sait jamais il est mort il est en classe
on peut le dire
et attention le moment que j'attends
depuis ces quatre heures de jeu oh oui
la liberté c'est super beau franchement
c'est megan aux adieux jeunes asile jiva
reculons j'ai peur qu'un mec qui
viennent le chopper pour me ramener de
danse et jamais un l'esprit ne s'est pas
enfui et ça c'est pas la voiture du mec
avec lequel on arrive dans l'asile là au
tout début du jeu je crois que c'est ça
non ce n'est pas parce qu'apparemment ce
dlc se passe avant le jeu au flag donc
j'en sais rien attendez attendez
attendez laissez démarré en fit toi mon
gars qui se croient aux promenades
parfois attendait rien mec c'est quoi
c'est qui s'approche la star où tu
changeras deux choses la radio le pétage
phase verra john and an plus tôt a
plutôt un putois
oui le bon gros deuil des familles on
s'enfuit s'en est sorti ou pas et là on
a juste un mec qui se réveille comme ça
bonjour fiston tu as bien dormi tiens
ton croissant si vous appuyez sur ce
bouton et de rappeler moyens de revenir
en arrière
il est assez de preuves accablantes de
ce fichier vidéo pour mettre nos amis de
murs comme dans la merde jusqu'au cou
vous êtes sorti de mon être massivement
en vie nous avons et nous avons tout
fait pour couvrir vos traces mais nos
ennemis sont aux aguets ce sont des
malveillants paranoïa capable de
déployer des ressources que votre sens
moral vous empêchez d'imaginer ce ne
serait pas la seule cible tout ce que
vous aimez votre fan de vos enfants
non non pas dans ça il ne représente
pour l'heure comme une façon de vous
toucher vous causerait un sourire et pas
mal aux compagnies vous pourriez même
approché d'une sorte de justice mais dès
que vous cliquerez sur transférer votre
vie sur un foutu mais qu'ils cachent
tous ceux que vous aimez son baiser ça
marche
mais ce serait la plus juste des
décisions ouvrira murkoff est si
important pour vous j'ai le choix ou pas
ah non j'ai pas le choix mais sur rien
mais oui trop sur la vidéo jamais
plusieurs fois par semaine en ligne des
vidéos
fin du jeu halo qui les a tous rendus
publics finalement il a pas vécu deux
jours et demi dans cette danse est en
droit de taré pour rien ah c'était
génial
[ __ ] et ben voilà les gens d'en
affiner que le dlc doubt la swiss life
du monde andrew r j'espère si vous aura
plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo ça me fait vraiment plaisir en
tout cas moi j'ai adoré ce dlc génial
génial si vous aimeriez qu'on fasse une
autre série de vidéos sur un jeu
n'hésitez pas à vous aimer la vidéo nom
se retrouve possible ne sera déconner tu
faisais encore auteur qu à tout le monde
m
oh